yeah like all these all these claims are
coming out and i'm like if you had
all year because you were complaining
things these things are going to happen
what did you do to prepare for that
impropriety in which case
look like i said earlier i think donald
trump should take it to the courts to
the full extent of the law
joe biden should uh defend litigate take
his own you know the path to the courts
the full extent of the law
we're entering law fair territory and
the winner is going to be the winner and
the supreme court might rule for trump
this is it's like
look i was a little kid when bush v gore
happened but people were
i don't know if you if you remember the
videos that came out like they were
egging the
the motorcade and like throwing tomatoes
and stuff not my president
and they had to like rush through i
vaguely remember this i could be wrong
because i was i think i was
13. you actually just made all of this
up there was no close race between bush
and gore it was like tim's dream
bush landslide everyone cheered they
were giving a thumbs up and then he was
like
he was like i'm going to go to war we're
going to go to iraq
we're going to go kill people could you
imagine if social media was
such a like like existed really yeah
back in 2000
you know what a nightmare that would be
oh my goodness yeah
facebook like existed well man
look we're here and i am i am really
worried i do believe
um i used to work at a homeless shelter
in california as a network of homeless
shelters
and one of the complaints we often got
was that once california notably los
angeles became one party rule they
stopped governing
they didn't need to yeah it was like
people just vote for you for no reason
it's great so maxine waters has stayed
in
yeah people just people just go in and
you know she's pretty good at what she
does she's pretty fantastic there's no
political competition at all no so they
just keep winning over and over again
and they don't have to do anything
and they don't do anything amazing they
often say that california is five years
ahead of the rest of the country
okay yeah yeah is that why they have
medieval diseases yes
they actually yeah and and you you best
be ready because
we're live years away from typhoid
outbreaks yeah i'm excited
but there there are a lot of things
about uh what happens in california
where they say it eventually
you know the policies make their way
doesn't what happens in california
unfortunately does not stay there
and this is i think we were talking
about this the other day but the the
role that california has played for the
rest of the country and the reason we've
tolerated them is because it's just a
place where all the people who vote very
stupidly
can sort of stay together but
unfortunately they've begun to spread
out and infect the rest of the country
i consider this to be a very serious
problem they're moving other places
they're turning them blue yeah because
they don't they they abandon california
because how horrible it's gotten and
then they vote for the things that make
california horrible
this is my point is we are dangerously
close to that happening
federally if the democrats take
everything
if they get the presidency the senate
and the house congratulations
it's it's going to be a brutal battle
for a while though because
you know at least we have an electoral
college but i think if they get to that
point there's no electrical college
so i want to well you need a two-thirds
majority to get rid of that right yeah
yeah yeah i am i don't want to insinuate
that this sounds at all suspicious
because like i like doing youtube
um but 538 tweeted unironically that
two more batches of pennsylvania vote
were reported then this was uh at 4pm
today but the
538 tweeted two more patches of
pennsylvania vote were reported
23 277 votes in philadelphia all for
biden
all of them every single one of them
every single one of the votes for biden
and then
about 5 300 votes um and i believe loser
and county not try to pronounce it
nearly 4 000 of which were provided
the fact that the first the first set 23
277 votes were all for
biden would be something i would
consider to be suspicious
if i wanted to get kicked off youtube i
would think that's strange i don't so i
think actually that's probably really
normal i don't know they'll kick me off
if you say it so i definitely think this
is really suspicious so i'm being
entirely honest
i mean it's it maybe it's part of that
uh
amazing voter fraud organization that
biden um
mistakenly that's an assumption
i'm not nate silver i do not know but i
mean it's maybe it's just the way he
worded the tweet maybe it doesn't mean
you know
all did you just vote you see what
happened in michigan but that's what he
said so i think it was michigan was it
michigan where
120 000 votes came in only for joe biden
i believe in wisconsin i mean
michigan and wisconsin both jumped up
like that very quickly without trump
gaining a single vote
i i do want to stress though i do want
to stress reporting errors
when the reporting error in arizona was
in trump's favor everyone's like oh oh
look look at here and then when they're
then when you have this reporting this
strange anomaly they're like well that
must be fraud it's like fair enough
yeah we don't know we don't know we're
staying on youtube but it
it has when those things happen
it's it's very everybody's very
sensitive right now so when you do see
that
you might react emotionally and think
wow that there's something there's there
might be something to you right
that's why i'm saying blame anybody for
that they they better investigate
as like the legitimate claims the ones
they can like the sharpie gate thing i
think
no what they need to do is just make
sure maybe do a recount or or
i don't know if a recount is even
necessary but make sure if you're in
arizona and use a sharpie just check
your ballot
and stay vigilant but if there are
legitimate fears and concerns and claims
like right now in michigan they're
boarding up the windows so no one can
see inside the poll counting walls i'm
like okay
why are you doing that for transparency
for transparency exactly yeah it makes
sense but people are outside and they're
like looking at the windows and filming
and then they start putting up boards so
no one could see in
oh no that is weird that's a little bit
weird that's like a weird thing if you
want we need off youtube
to point out listen listen robert reich
said
truth and reconciliation commissions
right okay well the first thing we have
to do to honor mr reich's wish is to
make sure that we have a full
investigation
of all of these so that we know for sure
who won if you're a democrat and you're
saying joe biden win get one get over it
then you should welcome
any and all challenge so once and for
all finally you can say to trump
you lose you lose every possible way in
every investigation and every attempt
and every legal battle you lost
you should want that to have trump be
able to say well
well i didn't oh no i'm so embarrassed
i'm gonna cry and run home
that seems like he's gonna say he's
gonna run to trump towers and go to
nobody wants to be my friend anymore no
i don't know and then trump is gonna
fall to his knees and scream at the sky
complete reverse he'll be part of one of
those uh
compilations with with all the girls
screaming it wouldn't be hilarious
no it's that dude what they want is for
it to be an exact reversal of trends
where
all the trump supporters are screaming
so you're gonna have like working class
people
with real jobs that are difficult like
construction workers just like screaming
and crying on the site like
like as if that would ever happen i
thought it was so revealing of the
psychology of the left
that it was actually left-leaning
outlets that were posting the videos of
kids who were upset and crying over it
as if we were gonna watch that and be
like oh well now i feel bad i shouldn't
have i shouldn't have voted for trump
what have i done how horrible uh is it's
like it's the optics of that are so
horrible but for whatever reason they
think that like if they cry will feel
bad for them and
and i think that that's why they think
everyone's a grifter they're like
why isn't sheamus crying he doesn't
really care he's lying
yeah like no i'm an adult man
and an adult i just period don't really
get that
emotional one way or the other yeah like
duncan this is really important to me i
think this this race has meant a lot
it's going to change the future of our
country in drastic ways i believe that
because
joe biden uh has won or if he does win
millions more unborn children will die
thousands more in the middle east will
die
and that's serious i do take that very
seriously but
what i take most seriously is is my soul
and the development of virtue and my
family
and if you have stock in those kinds of
things as opposed to just being obsessed
with the political process and nothing
else
then uh you have some perspective that
results in you not crying when your
candidate loses an election
exactly even if you recognize the
seriousness of such a thing occurring
can can we can we talk about um
people crying about on the internet uh
can we cry right now just kidding i was
just kidding i want to let go let's all
cry together well
i i mean that just kind of makes me
think about
how social media uh like who who do you
think are their loudest voices
on twitter the left or the right the
left definitely
okay yeah they are it's a fact jack
dorsey is very loud because we we
we talk about how the media uh
definitely
you know the media and the polling are
helping to skew
and uh the narrative and and make
everybody
think that that their candidate that joe
biden is gonna that there's gonna be a
blue wave
and there wasn't and there wasn't it's
the same thing when like
look if the loudest voices got their way
like we
andrew yang would be president yep you
know
because they the yang gang were like the
loudest people
on the planet you know with their little
blue hat avatars in there
in their names but it's see
it's it's oh no no go ahead please no no
well had had trump won the blue wave
would have been
liberal tears but unfortunately that
might not be the case
he might be losing i don't know it's
still it's still it's still a toss-up
though we really don't know
well i'd say it's a toss-up just because
the media is untrustable you can't trust
them
and we need certified results before
anything
in which case the left right now is
already there their hubris is showing
men
and you better be careful i'll say right
now i got no idea who wins if biden wins
well you know best of luck to biden and
camel i don't really like them very much
and i'll hold their feet to the fire if
they do things i think they're going to
do and you know we'll move on with our
lives we'll keep running our businesses
we'll
take care of our families and we're not
going to cry about it
uh uh-huh yeah be mature
i guess well i mean yeah i i don't think
we're gonna
i mean did you see earlier that you see
the video of the
the nevada secretary of state or there
was there was somebody talking about
uh their election process and some guy
came out in a shirt that said like
barbecue or something started screaming
like you know
no cobin's a criminal oh yeah
yeah it was pretty funny yeah and that's
going in the montage
yeah exactly and that and that's that's
the thing uh
what why is it of course the loudest
people are also
you know some of the craziest people too
what are you talking about
twitter twitter won't ban them is a
thing right well they're on tick tock
hold on that's true they're all 15.
i think it's going to be really
interesting to not have a president for
a little while
we don't if joe well i mean we don't
know who the official victor is
no no no no no no we don't have a
president elect yet no no i mean joe
biden
he's not going to be a president that's
true he's not yeah they're going to be
like uh
this this is not going to be the
senate's going to walk up to him and be
like
sign this bill that uh you know green
new deal and he's going to go oh
jim all right he's going to just like
scribble on it
and it's going to be like signing over
his power of return to some random guy
but how many bills do you think he's
actually going to be
signing with mitch mcconnell as i mean
none
he's going to sign more executive orders
than trump ever did
some random guy's going to show up to
his house and be like uh i'm hunter and
he's going to go
hunter yeah i'm i'm hunter uh sign this
document for our ukrainian energy
business
okay and then he signs it and he's like
signing over his bank account
he's like some random guy we're gonna
we're gonna have a president
look man i'm not trying to be mean but
come on yes you are tim
nobody should delete your channel nobody
who voted for biden voted for biden
they voted against donald trump thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when
we go live don't forget to subscribe hit
the like button
hit the notification bell and we are
also available on all podcast platforms
for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time